foreign
[Music]
for Wednesday November 16th I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
the United Nations climate change
conference or comp27 in Shamel Sheikh
Egypt wraps up this week and despite
past Promises by many of the world's
governments the United Nations predicts
that on the current path global
temperatures will rise by 4.5 degrees by
the end of the century here's U.N
Secretary General Antonio guterres
speaking at the conference last week
Humanity has a choice cooperate or Paris
it is either a climate solidarity pact
or a collective suicide pact
that dire warning comes a year after a
U.N report said Rising global
temperatures are leading to more extreme
weather conditions to prepare for those
the UN is working to expand a network of
weather stations that act like a global
early warning system but for that system
to work it needs more data and
collecting that data comes with some
hurdles joining us to discuss this is
wsj reporter Eric neeler hi Eric thanks
for joining me hi Zoe nice to be with
you so first off can you tell us a
little bit about what these early
warning systems are warning us about
well they're really for people on the
ground just like we have weather
forecast that we get in the United
States wherever you live that warns us
of short-term things it's going to be
raining this weekend to we're going to
be entering a dry spell for the summer
or it looks like there's a hurricane
season with 15 hurricanes in the next
three months so there's short-term and
medium-term predictions that they're
working on but it turns out in large
parts of the world these kind of
forecasts just aren't available
obviously you would expect a lot of
information to to go into making these
predictions but I thought quite a lot of
that data came from satellites and could
then be provided from countries where
you know these data scientists and
analysts were based well that is true I
mean it's half the equation right
satellites provide you with a broad
coverage they can look at Sea surface
temperatures they can look at
atmospheric temperatures at different
levels in the atmosphere but there
really no substitute for the on the
ground measurements that are really key
things like temperature wind speed
barometric pressure a lot of these
things they get from a little
meteorological station what's really uh
funny I learned that weather balloons
launching a weather balloons is really
important because it gives you a whole
profile of the whole atmosphere and
gives you all kinds of information and
these weather balloons just aren't
available and aren't being used in many
many countries in the developing world
you mentioned weather balloons but what
else do they need to set up these data
collection efforts well they need
training they need equipment they need
computer software and Technical know-how
to take this data and make something
with it so what you do is you collect a
lot of data you put it into an existing
computer model that may give you say a
seasonal look at what's coming ahead or
even just a measurement of a heat wave
that may be coming in the next two or
three weeks but what you really need is
consistent high quality weather data and
that's the problem here that a lot of
countries that we're talking about don't
have the people or the equipment or the
training to provide that kind of high
quality data so what efforts
specifically then are the UN and some of
the Nations involved with this program
doing to get not just the equipment but
the people needed to collect and analyze
the data so the UN has initiated a big
program they've just barely gotten it
off the ground this year at the cop 27
climate Summit in Egypt where I was last
week and I was speaking with a couple of
folks about that some of the officials
from the UN but also some of the people
who are going to be using that data so
what they're going to do is really
expand the number of weather stations
across large parts of Asia sub-Saharan
Africa and the island states in the
Pacific and the Caribbean where you're
really not getting much data at all NOAA
the National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration they plan to train 200
people over the next five years bring
them to the United States conferring
with them
and really teaching them how to use the
models how to take the models that we
have now tailor it to their Homeland are
there places where this kind of
collaboration is already taking place
sure no has already started working with
the country of Senegal this is a West
African nation that's been experiencing
real problems with heat and that is
affecting your population not just
Farmers or businesses but the health of
people who live there so they are
collaborating with Noah on a sort of a
heat advisory system that will give
better information about heat waves that
are coming one to two weeks ahead of
time are there any other major hurdles
to setting up these early Warning
Systems well who's going to pay for all
this the initial project is 50 million
dollars from nine donor countries in the
Nordic Development Bank that kind of got
things going but the officials at the UN
say they want 3.1 billion dollars over
the next five years to really cover the
whole planet who's going to fund that
the United States and the European
countries which are also being asked to
pay for other sorts of environmental and
climate related funding mechanisms or is
there a role for Private Industry we
haven't quite seen that yet this has so
far been a government-to-government
project but I would imagine in time that
there may be a role for Private Industry
these are still predictions I mean even
with an increased amount of data how
accurate do they tend to be the
short-term forecasts are getting pretty
good seasonal forecasts have been
improved even more in the last five to
eight years according to NOAA people the
medium term forecasts that go say three
to six months are getting better and
better in the last five to eight years
and you know these are also feeding into
larger what we call climate models which
looking years down the road so accuracy
is improving that's being driven by
better computing power and better data
and that has real impacts for how people
make decisions with say their trucking
business or whether they decide to
invest in a certain country or even
whether a farmer decides to plant now or
in three weeks you mentioned the need
for funding and a lot of it coming from
governments that are already being asked
to fund other climate initiative you
know these are telling us about
potential weather catastrophes but is
this data in any way helping prevent or
slow climate change which has been the
un's goal for many years now data is
important to knowing what's coming down
the road and that's important for
societies for businesses for People's
Health so data is very important for
planning it's not going to slow climate
change it's not going to reduce the
amount of greenhouse gas emissions in
the air that's only going to happen with
changes in policies throughout the globe
but these climate early warning systems
are going to help all of us prepare for
what's coming make decisions in the
short medium and long term that can
affect our lives our businesses and our
families all right that's wsj reporter
Eric nealer Eric thanks so much for
explaining this to us you're welcome
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories check out
our website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]